This male Arctic fox
has spent the last six months
alone.
He really goes the distance
when food is in short supply.
One even clocked
more than a thousand miles
in just over two months.
This little guy
has been surviving off his street smarts.
You can't be too careful
when you're only 12 inches tall
In the Arctic
even leftovers are a reason to celebrate.
With spring in the air
he's heading home to reunite
with his lifelong mate.
They spent the long winter apart
searching for food.
He must find her.
If there's any hope of starting a family.
Maybe she hasn't survived
the winter.
Ah, there she is.
Together again.
Time to get on with the business
of becoming a mom and dad
and to raise their litter of pups before
the end of summer.